lymphop people qu'il ne fallait pas
louper cette semaine c'est le retour
d'une star de la chanson celui de Mylène
Farmer vendredi Mylène Farmer sortira
donc l'emprise son douzième album est
parti en tournée dès le mois de juin une
journée qui passera notamment par le
Vélodrome et le Stade de France
[Musique]
rare dans les médias depuis quelques
temps la chanteuse a pourtant accordé
une interview au Journal du dimanche où
elle se livre avec sincérité je vis le
moment présent je refuse de me projeter
c'est une angoisse terrible pour moi je
pensais tout arrêter sa santé son avenir
l'actualité retour sur l'interview de
Mylène Farmer dans le JDD
[Applaudissements]
les mises en scène extraordinaires qui a
pu faire et surtout le fait que son
personnage mais elle l'a travaillé dans
les médias elle a été ultra médiatisée
dans les années 90 elle faisait toutes
les émissions de variété de
divertissement elle a disparu le
contrôle elle a travaillé son image et
le fait d'être rare la rang mais
exceptionnelle en soi
est-ce que Mylène Farmer en une d'un
people c'est vendeur
de moins en moins ça l'a beaucoup pété
oui parce qu'en fait les jeunes parce
que les jeunes aussi achètent les gens
me people s'intéressent pas forcément à
Mylène Farmer donc après ça dépend de
quel magazine people on parle donc je
vais pas rentrer dans le détail mais ça
ne vend plus autant qu'avant je pense
qu'elle a plus sa place dans le JDD
aujourd'hui mais là aussi ça dépend la
voix
en concert comme à chaque fois
d'ailleurs je me balayais en
mousquetaire et et c'est vrai que son
public avis avec elle c'est vrai que il
y a pas de non mais c'est vrai il y a
pas de aujourd'hui elle est plus France
dimanche que
[Musique]
la plus investie de France parce que
c'est incroyable les gens avec elle il
la suivent et elle se montre pas et on
peut pas ne pas l'aimer c'est pourquoi
parce qu'elle fait pas de base c'est
qu'en fait elle elle ne parle jamais on
peut dire des choses
elle est incroyable elle a rempli donc
tous les stades ça de France les stades
attendez c'est pas qu'en France elle a
rempli en Russie et elle a rempli en
Italie elle a rempli en Russie c'est
c'est c'est incroyable mon chéri a avec
elle lors de sa tournée en Russie il y a
son chéri il est bodyguard il était le
bodyguard de Mylène Farmer Mylène Farmer
et c'est et c'est un amour
et c'est une mais c'est une méga star en
Russie et même à la Rival à l'aéroport
aujourd'hui de parce que elle a jamais
beaucoup parlé là elle a dit plein de
choses elle s'exprime sur la fin du par
exemple se protège beaucoup dans le truc
quand même
merci alors elle a quand même elle a
révélé en fait elle est revenue elle a
confirmé un peu l'air de rien une rumeur
lancée par la presse people et
particulièrement par closer il y a
quelques mois parce qu'elle sait elle
s'est séparée du réalisateur réalisateur
Benoît dit Sabatino qui était son
compagnon depuis 20 ans et là elle donne
une interview elle parle
depuis 20 ans j'en connais des autres
quoi Benjamin je vous jure
le sujet ce qui est important c'est que
la personne c'était pas la peine de vous
parler là
son album s'appelle emprise et elle est
interrogée par le journaliste sur le
fait voilà c'est un album
autobiographique est-ce qu'elle a été
victime d'un pervers narcissique etc et
elle le dit elle dit voilà on a tous été
victime plus ou moins on a tous
rencontré un pervers narcissique à un
moment donné donc ce qu'elle dit est
quand même assez violent visiblement ça
te fait beaucoup rire mais c'est réel
c'est ma vie qui me fait rire
non mais c'est vrai non mais elle
s'adresse à toutes les femmes qui se et
pas que les femmes à tous ceux qui
subissent ce genre de pression de choses
et ce qu'elle dit est quand même assez
important c'est repris partout et elle
confirme aussi et ça c'est tout l'art de
Mylène Farmer qu'elle a un très très
lourd secret à dissimuler le journaliste
lui demande elle fait oui mais
laissons-le là où il est le soir alors
je connais son secret
je vous jure je connais son secret mais
je ne peux pas le dire ici
il me reste une fan c'est mamie
en fait parce que je veux dire comment
vous faites je vais lancer un appel si
vous regardez ces clips dans un certain
ordre non mais
[Rires]
si vous regardez ce clip dans un certain
ordre c'est un peu comme vous rappeler
de Tintin
les secrets des licornes
dedans en fait ce qui veut donner
l'emplacement d'un secret bon si vous
regardez les clips je vous jure que ça
va il y a des codes et vous il y a un
code à trouver de Mylène Farmer à la fin
portable et public et vous découvrez
vous découvrez vous découvrirez votre
j'adore est-ce que
là
alors
c'est également confié sur le fait
qu'elle était pas capable d'écrire des
mots un seul mot des phrases
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
différemment que à travers ses chansons
voilà
[Rires]
c'est intéressant
c'était ces textes de chansons
dans les interviews avec distille
toujours des petits messages si on les
lie elle dit beaucoup de choses elle
parle elle revient sur sa relation elle
dit des choses assez fortes assez
violentes auxquelles beaucoup de gens
peuvent s'identifier et c'est là
toujours sur le pervers narcissique là
d'accord
elle parle d'elle aussi elle parle de
ses chansons mais ses chansons sont
toujours liées aussi à ce qu'elle vit
c'est ça aussi ah oui et oui si tu
regardes toute la discographie Mylène
Farmer c'est un peu toujours lié à ce
qu'elle vit après je suis pas un fan
mais ça serait quelle période une
période ça avait 15 ans donc c'est toi
qui dois le dire
non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que
Mylène en vrai vu qu'on a pas l'habitude
de l'entendre faire des interviews ou
autre et ben dans ces musiques à la
possibilité de se livrer et il y a pas
mal d'artistes en fait qui sont comme ça
ou moi-même en tant qu'animateur radio
par exemple l'autre fois j'ai reçu Rohff
et je l'ai posé la question je lui ai
dit que il y a des gens qui ne te
connaissent pas directement il m'a dit
en fait dans mes chansons je me livre et
ils comprenait pas comment les gens ne
le connaissaient pas là je disais ah oui
ok d'accord et là je comprends mieux que
des artistes comme Mylène qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de faire des interviews en
fait dans ces dans leur musique ce livre
et là on a après elle a quand même
ouvert la brèche de la communication il
y a deux trois ans avec un documentaire
sur Amazon Prime vidéo où elle filmait
le processus de création de ces concerts
de la communication parce que ce compte
en banque peut-être
par les femmes on l'a vu à plusieurs
reprises à RTL pardon ben oui sans
déconner pas moi mais mes sculpture oui
de ces interviews elle a un côté un peu
dans l'esprit tout le monde jusqu'au
bout Mylène Farmer même pour les jeunes
même s'ils connaissent pas leurs
chansons comme Johnny c'est comme je ne
sais même pas de donner lui donner un
âge non c'est vrai honnêtement
ah bah voilà merci beaucoup